the corona virus pandemic has strained
health systems around the world and now
it's caused the uninterrupted growth of
the world's second largest economy to
falter for the first time in decades for
the first quarter of 2020 China's GDP
contracted by 6.8 percent the current
external situation is more complex
domestic demand remains comparatively
weak companies still face difficulties
such as insufficient demand and dropping
orders preventative measures so China's
economic activity slowed to a trickle
for nearly two months
local infections have eased and some
businesses and factories have resumed
operations but many companies are on the
brink of collapse
this situation is dire that's just for
me I've got no idea how I can get
through this year China's National
Statistics Bureau says the economy would
bounce back in the second quarter and
long-term growth won't be affected but
with global demand plummeting its
economy faces an uphill battle globally
so which leads to a lot of countries
including the US and European countries
into a recession
so that will lead to a decrease in
demand of China's products
China's central bank has cut interest
rates and provided tax breaks and
subsidies to businesses in need but
analysts say it would be enough to
stabilize employment finding work will
be more difficult for graduates and
migrant workers especially and while
economic growth has plummeted China's
corvid 19 death toll has been revised
upwards after a formal review officials
in the original epicenter of Wuhan
increased the number by 1290 saying
previous records were incomplete
China's coronavirus count has been
adjusted several times in recent months
this latest change is further fueling
suspicion over the accuracy of
government figures many critics believe
that the official tally of the
82000 falls well short of the real
numbers on the ground Katrina you
al-jazeera
Beijing more now on the increase in the
Wuhan death toll anni sparrow is a
professor of population health science
and policy at the archives School of
Medicine at Mount Sinai
she says the whu-oh has no independent
way of verifying the numbers even though
it appears like a religion on the
surface and is it's a small religion as
we've heard and compared with what we
think the numbers really are once we saw
the trajectories in Italy even for
example and the death rate that
accompanied there it became apparent you
know increasingly apparent how suspect
China's numbers were now the original
religion has been done with that in the
independent scrutiny so director has no
way to actually verify any of this but
has no independent accesses these are
only official figures and no non
official killers are allowed so itself
crypts and not an actual changing
methodology as we know China originally
if you died without a testable then you
weren't counted as a Kovach death now
China is not alone in adopting that kind
of methodology but given that it was the
first country that then we are
particularly worried about that because
it was this type of cover-up that
enabled the virus to spread and the
spread and become the pandemic that we
have today